comme ça au fort comme qualitas ils sont
nombreux aujourd'hui à venir récupérer
leur commande à l'antenne de paris
charcuterie mangue litchi bouchons et
autres spécialités culinaires sont
arrivés tout droit de la réunion la
veille
tout a été choisi avec soin auprès des
producteurs locaux
et c'est bien la qualité les clients
viennent chercher mais je suis venu
chercher ma commande de letchis
c'est un petit peu le seul endroit où on
les trouve étaient ils sont bons parce
qu'on en trouve ailleurs parfois ils
semblent ils sont plutôt noir du coup je
me retirais des fruits qui viennent la
réunion qu'on sait que c'est des bons
fruits et pour offrir voilà pour noël la
famille alors j'ai commandé des bonbons
piments des samoussas et des bouchons
aussi là nous sommes dans le stock on a
au total plus de 900 commandes passées
soit près de 400 kg de litchi plus de
400 langues
en tout ces 2500 article qui attendent
leurs clients alors à la boutique de la
réunion c'est l'effervescence
toutes les équipes sont mobilisées pour
servir au mieux les clients
un moment fort de l'année qui répondent
aux missions de l'antenne de paris notre
antenne se veut avant tout être une
cellule d'information de relais
d'orientation et d'animation en soutien
donc à notre communauté réunionnaise nés
en métropole leur apporter un peu de
chaleur humaine leur permettre comme
tout comme les réunionnais de pouvoir
fêter noël avec des produits typiques de
la réunion les ananas 24 la passion et
il est vrai que cette livraison spéciale
à quelques jours des fêtes était
attendue avec impatience
ça fait quatre ans que je suis à paris
et j'ai toujours besoin d'eux mêmes et
produits réunionnais pour les fêtes
donc voilà je suis venu récupérer mais
litchi mes mangas et mes fruits de la
passion pour pouvoir offrir aux proches
et à la fois profiter de débits de
produits locaux
les parisiens ont jusqu'au 23 décembre
récupérer leur commande ou profiter des
autres produits disponibles dans la
boutique
[Musique]